Republicans are endorsing Ron DeSantis
for president even though he's not
actually running yet this is a very
interesting situation is it unique
though we'll answer that question in a
moment first here is a video from a
couple of weeks ago from Jeb Bush a
former governor of Florida who uh says
he likes DeSantis even though DeSantis
is not at this point in time a candidate
I think it's pretty remarkable and he
hasn't declared yet many in the
Republican Party hoped soon will
as this Ron desantis's opportunity to
run for higher office I think it is he's
been a really effective Governor he's
young I think we're on the verge of a
generational change in our politics I
kind of hope so I think it's time for a
more forward-leaning future oriented uh
conversation or Politics as well which
has made him should he choose to run for
the president a serious contender in
Republican politics and who better to do
it than someone who's been outside of
Washington who's governed effectively
who I think has shown that Florida could
be a model for the future of our country
yeah now remember Florida's rankings are
very mediocre ranked between 20th and
30th and most indicators as I told you
but put that aside for a second that
sounded like a pretty full-throated
endorsement by Jeb Bush of Ronda santis
he later said I was praising not
endorsing DeSantis but he is clearly
making public statements that he likes
DeSantis for president even though
DeSantis is not actually a candidate yet
we have another example of this rep
Republican chip Roy has now endorsed Ron
DeSantis for president putting out a
statement uh two days ago saying the
next president of the uh well it's
called Ron DeSantis for president and he
says the next president of the United
States must be a vibrant and energetic
leader with the faith vision and courage
to chart a new course America needs a
leader who will truly defend her and
empower the people against the
destructive force of unrestrained
government and corporate excess
profligate spending and woke cultural
indoctrination that leader says chip Roy
is Ron Florida Governor Ron DeSantis a
man of conviction a man who puts his
faith in God first as a dedicated
husband and father he grew up a
blue-collar kid who worked hard got a
great education and used it immediately
to serve his country he loves America
unapologetically but loves freedom and
the rule of law even more with the
courage to fight for both yeah not the
freedom for teachers to teach what they
determine is best to teach not the
freedom for Disney to support the causes
it wants to support without risking
losing it yeah you you guys it's a very
short-sighted version of Freedom so is
it normal or common for non-candidates
to be endorsed is this something we've
seen in the history of the United States
we've seen it a few times it's not the
most common thing
in 1924
former president Teddy Roosevelt was
endorsed for the presidency by the
Progressive Party despite the fact that
he had not announced his candidacy and
Roosevelt declined the nomination but it
certainly raised the profile of the
Progressive Party in 1960 Dwight D
Eisenhower endorsed vice president
Richard Nixon for the Republican
nomination Nixon at that point had not
formally announced his candidacy and
then in 2020 former president Barack
Obama endorsed Joe Biden even though at
that point Biden had also not officially
announced but it was one of these
situations where it was pretty clear and
written on the wall that an announcement
was forthcoming so long story short it
is not super common
to see someone who isn't running
endorsed and when we see them endorsed
it is often the case that they are close
to an announcement so do I believe
DeSantis will announce or as some of you
have written to me do I think the
scientists will use this as a waiting
game and end up sitting aside until 2028
I lean towards the scientists will run
24 but I'm still very much open to the
idea that I'm wrong why because I'm
wrong all the time in my predictions and
so I don't I have zero confidence in any
of my own predictions imagine for a
second that you try logging into your
email account only to find that your
password was changed an hour ago and
then you get notifications of activity
from your bank and then your credit
cards that is what identity theft is
like and it's a horrible feeling and we
dealt with it at the show not that long
ago but now I have an app called Aura
which gives me much more Peace of Mind
our sponsor Aura is the all-in-one
solution for keeping your online account
safe because Aura will scan the dark web
for your personal info passwords social
security number and you get fast alerts
when they find something you also get
fast alerts about credit inquiries Aura
protects all of your devices from
malware or even requests the removal of
your info from data broker sites and
Aura helps you manage what your kids can
do on their devices you can restrict
certain apps set screen time limits set
Focus times when you need them off of
devices go to aura.com Pacman to try it
free for seven days your login
credentials might already be floating
around out there and Aura will tell you
instantly for free the link is down
below